[Applaudissements]
j'étais m qu'est ce qu'il ya laisse moi
sur un succès sur ce je sais que si je
perds pas avoir les mêmes conclusions
donc c'est pas bon annoncé d'abord un
mauvais perdant vraiment vous pouvez
perdre
[Applaudissements]
si vous perdez je vous jure que c'est
vrai ah ah bah je me fout à poil et je
fais totalement je fais le tour de
france soit vers les remous par contre
si vous perdez c'est la honte pour vous
donc le fresnoy exprimant parce que les
gens c'est moi aussi j'étais au sport tu
te l'avait juré que vous ne faites pas
exprès non je fais pas ça ne sera jamais
le chanteur pop de perdre tu te met à
poil
j'ai envie de voir un jour j'ai jamais
eu mais pas le faire
on fait
on saura si c'est fait exprès et 6 kg 2
points attention vous les prenez à bout
de bras comme si juste une question car
si jamais j'ai les 500 signatures
d'ailleurs que je vais faire les
émissions de pujadas des paroles et des
actes
après des débats et on va le jouer à
fond après comme un havre a perdu 1,1
attention mathieu abattre tous les
rappeurs à ce jour ça et vous savez ce
que j'ai pu j'ai eu un petit message de
booba a way
mais ne vous entendez bien que booba bon
eh bien il va peut-être passer aussi et
tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
godiva 4e 29 à l'ego car il fait pas
commencé après 17 ans de rose et de
leurs mômes et son honneur aussi un
casque ou mathieu 1
j'ai toujours été fan ducalcon mathieu
là mais je suis un peu cramé au genre du
mur elle tient quand même on s'en fout
de ce que ça va quand même temps hanouna
poil autour de berne est en cela m'est
arrivé aussi carissimi des clarisses tu
sais que j'étais toujours aimé qu'on
sait qu'on est quelqu'un que j'adore ça
fait combien de semaines que je veux tu
es dans l'émission ça fait combien de
fois que je dis de venir
tu peux pas me faire ça car ici avec à
risques a renchéri sans égal et non pas
ce que tu veux la défense
la chose se défend s'il a dit ça déjà ça
sert à rien que pour ça je vais vous
dire un belge aurait d'autres raisons
comme au foot à pois rimac était pas
mathieu mathieu et on m'a dit ah bon
vous l'avez jamais vu mais là j'ai fait
ce port pin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là dessus